hat christian beer die umgebracht
seine verbrecherkarriere begann vor 28
jahren
das war 1992 seine erste aktenkundige
tat ein einbruch ist es sehr sehr
auffällig das ist erst mal quer durchs
strafgesetzbuch
also erscheint im regal berufskriminelle
zu sein schwerpunkte liegen allerdings
immer bei sexualstraftaten bei
drogenhandel auch bei herstellung von
drogen da geht's auch einmal quer durch
von synthetischen drogen bei cannabis
und andere dinge und einbruchsdiebstahl
erscheint also richtig seinen
lebensunterhalt auf der einen seite mit
bestritten zu haben und auf der anderen
seite immer wieder auch diese
sexualstraftaten deswegen er momentan
auch in der jva sitzen und diese tat ihm
da vorgeworfen wird ist aus dem jahre
2005 auch an der algarve da handelt sich
um eine ältere dame die liste der
gefängnisaufenthalte von christian b ist
2017 saß er wegen kinderpornografie und
wegen sexuellen missbrauchs von kindern
wegen dem verstoß gegen das
betäubungsmittelgesetz und
vergewaltigung 2019 und 2020 wieder
wegen dem verstoß gegen das
betäubungsmittelgesetz was auch noch
auffällt an der akt ist dass die taten
in deutschland 95 enden und 2007 wieder
beginnen
und das ist ja genau die zeit in der er
sich an der algarve aufgehalten haben
soll und wo die polizei davon ausgeht
dass in diesem zeitraum auch die tat an
mittelfeld